I wonder if you can see me
because I'm not seeing myself in the
preview mirror over there
at the very least I assume you can hear
me
not sure what's going on
hey okay so people are here at least
hello
hi so can you tell me
if you can see me right now or if it's
just
if it's just the audio you can see me
okay good because I'm trying out
a new setup here
in which I should be able to use my
actual camera
this one right rather than the crappy
webcam
so I hope I hope the the image quality
is a little better than it usually is
how's everyone doing
I haven't done one of these and it was a
low volume okay let's let's do how about
this
there's an echo
like huh
shouldn't be oh I know why
how about now
I think I was picking up both
the microphone and the the the camera
stuff like the camera audio at the same
time
is this better
okay so still echoing
really shouldn't be an echo at this
point okay so it's better now okay good
hi everyone
good to see you I haven't done one of
these uh one of these live streams in a
while
a couple of months actually it's been a
pretty crazy summer which is weird
because
you'd think that the summer
is
calmer since I don't have my day job so
I work at a school or I did work at a
school and so we're basically off for
the whole summer which it was like oh
great now I can just
do
less or like focus on doing videos but
instead
I probably worked harder and more during
the summer than I did over the previous
year so I'm a little tired uh but at the
same time it's been a great I've had a
great summer it's been really wonderful
um trying to sort of process the whole
experience of
of being a teacher
so I worked as a teacher at a school for
the previous two years
so an English teacher and essentially
like a student assistant
which was essentially the most
meaningful wonderful experience I've
ever had in my life the most spiritually
fulfilling and
just all of that stuff
compared to reading all these books and
studying all these Mystics and
philosophers I mean that's nothing in
comparison to to doing this job and so I
was so grateful and so happy and so
just ecstatic that I that I
was given that opportunity and so when
that ended because the students went off
to a different school and I don't work
there anymore that was a very uh intense
experience and so I had to process that
over the course of the summer too
anyway
I was gonna
just
do a little stream I'll answer some
questions if you have any questions you
can put them in the chat
and I'll try my best to
answer them because I haven't done one
of these in a while
um
luban Mira asks if I'm a professor I'm
not I'm not a professor I worked as an
English teacher in Student Assistance
that was basically for people in fifth
grade
um
but still uh incredible stuff I have a I
have a master's degree in in comparative
religion I don't have a PhD yet
but so no I'm not at the level of being
a professor at this point
um
Arman asks if I have any advice for
studying Islam
that's a good question I guess I mean
there are courses you can take in Islam
and in religion
um
you would really have to sort of pick
um
a certain topic within Islam I guess and
then I could it would be easier to give
you book recommendations and stuff like
that because Islam and any religion is
such a huge topic so
um there are I mean there are good
introductory books
um there's one by John Esposito that's
pretty good we use that as course
literature when I studied
at first
you could read stuff like
Martin Link's book about Muhammad is a
classic I mean that's you of course you
have to keep in mind that that's uh
from within the traditions and that's
retelling the the stories about Muhammad
from within the Islamic tradition so
it's not sort of an academic approach in
that way but it's still sort of a good
introduction to the basic uh Narrative
of the origins of the religion that's a
really good book
um
but yeah check out some of those basic
sort of overview
books that you use in course literature
like books called Islam
and in Islam in its history or something
like that I try to think of any
particular ones because they're escaping
my memory at the moment
um
a lot of questions a lot of good
questions I'll of course won't be able
to get to all of them but I'll pick a
few out here
let's see
Sarah asked if I get it if I get annoyed
when I keep getting questions about
Islam No I I enjoy talking about Islam I
think Islam is a religion that is has a
very rich tradition that is very
interesting to talk about and there's of
course a lot of misconceptions about
Islam and so I'm happy to to inform and
educate on that topic and then
dispel many of those misconceptions if
if they exist
but of course I do love talking about
other religions too so as long as I get
to do that also then I'm happy
see
uh Sarah again
asks if I ever uh read the Quran I have
read the Quran
not sure if I read the whole thing I
probably read the whole thing
um throughout the years I've read
sections like the shorts pseudos I've
written Arabic too since I
kind of know how to read Arabic a little
bit so and I enjoyed that I mean it's a
it's a different experience to read than
Arabic of course as it always is to read
those kinds of works and and poetry and
stuff in the original languages
uh but as if we make videos
yes I've been thinking about that
because I'm currently working on a video
about malasadra
which is long in the making and so the
the one of the reasons that it's taken
me so long to to make that video in
particular is that I felt like to
understand molassadra properly or to do
a video on molassadra you first need to
have you know the three basic
Traditions or philosophers that he's
drawing from which is IBN Cena
and IBN Arabi and so I've done at this
point I've done one video each way I
have a video and I've been seeing I have
one Arabian one on survivorian so now I
can sort of tackle molassadra I guess
but I feel like the IBN Cena video which
is one of the First videos I did on this
channel that was back in 2018
not that I think it's a bad video or
anything but I can certainly do that one
better and I think even Cena deserves
something better than that it's very
short for example it's like 16 minutes
for like the greatest philosopher of in
the history of the Islamic tradition so
definitely you know I've been Cena in
particular I want to go back and redo
that episode at some point
Stellar Ray asks
would you have a video on Scientology
sure
I mean I open to doing videos about
basically anything and I think a lot of
those contemporary religious movements
just
new religious movements in generally
something that I want to get into a lot
more and Scientology is one of those
I don't know much about scientology at
the moment you know you've seen the
documentaries and heard all this stuff
which is mostly really uh frightening
and negative stuff and you know I'm sure
a lot of that is is true of course but
the I I feel like I would need to have a
better
overview of all the different
perspectives and and all that before I
can do that but that's certainly
something I would love to do in the
future
okay a lot of Islam questions and again
I'm happy to answer Islam questions but
I'm gonna also see if there is
something else
speaking of my my work as a teacher one
of my
beloved students is actually in the chat
right now hey Michael
let's see
so what is my other people asking me
what my religion is and I've sort of
have sort of answered that question
before in one of my q and A's but
it's it's uh
it's really something I try to keep away
from answering because well for one
thing the answer is complicated but also
um
you know it's just something that I kind
of you know the details of that I guess
I want to keep private for now
retro Chad
asks if I think religion is good or bad
for society that's a very complex
question
um there might be a video
in which I am involved with which is
going to come out soon maybe that deals
with that question
um
I think neither and both
um
religion can have a positive impact in
people's lives and can provide meaning
it can provide structure and and all
these things social coherence and all
this in people's lives but it is also of
course led to to
oppression and warn all these kinds of
things a lot of other things can lead to
those things too I'm not of the opinion
you know you hear that people say that
religion is the source of all evil I
don't think that's true I think that's a
very simplified way to look at things
I think that
religion is essentially what people make
make it out to be so if people want to
use a religion to do
bad things in the world and they will do
that and if they want to use religion to
do good things and then that can be a
very helpful tool for that too so
religion is whatever people make it out
to be
Justin from esoterica is in the chat
I'm gonna get your question first but
soon but first i'm going to get to this
Super Chat thank you so much I see Sarah
Sen
uh he says I'm not sure if your
knowledge of geopolitics is good
not anymore but can you do a video about
Confucianism Shintoism Buddhism and
taoism and I would influence into
today's Asian politics in China it's
that's a really interesting uh topic
absolutely I did one on Shinto
which I think I touched on some
political aspects I have to go back and
re-watch that but
but yeah definitely I mean confusionism
Andrew Henry from religion for breakfast
did a wonderful series on Confucianism
and so I don't feel a huge need to to
cover that topic right now because
because I feel like he kind of nailed it
and I don't know what else I could add
but
certainly you know discussing the
relationship between these different
religions in China and how they interact
with politics and so on is a really
interesting topic that I would love to
to cover okay so Justin
what EXT oh no what extinct religion do
you wish were still around
it's a fascinating question uh
I mean
I mean what religions would count as
extinct like is manichaism
extinct
because there are people who identify as
Mana key and today
but not sure that that's sort of a
continuous tradition from antiquity
man I had to think about this one
in many key let's say manichaeism
is extinct
and I would love to I would love to see
some mannequins around because I think
that's a really cool and fascinating
religion I would just like to know
how that religion was was practiced
and how the the sort of what they call
the elect what was the relationship
there between the elect and then the and
the people I would love to just to see
that religion and action I guess I'm
gonna think more about your question
because that was a really good one
book recommendations lands I mean
yeah a lot depending on what you wanna
study
um
I read a great book recently
I forget
LM how much do you know about Ethiopian
tower heater Orthodoxy it has a very
distinct features of spirituality and
mysticism than hezekism
I don't know much
um
actually
I have I'm sort of touching on Ethiopian
Orthodox Christianity in an upcoming
video because I'm doing a video now I'm
working on one about these scenes
and and the Dead Sea Scrolls and the
possible connection between those
and so of course discussing the dead
screen Dead Sea Scrolls the books of
Enoch comes up
come up and
the
Ethiopian Orthodox Church of course has
the Book of Enoch as part of their
biblical Canon which makes them unique
and that's really interesting
but more I don't know
I don't have any extensive knowledge of
that tradition actually
and that's what's so great about
studying religion and making videos
about religion because there's always
new stuff to learn
I'm gonna be you know I could do this
forever right because you can just
there's so many topics and there are so
many nuances and aspects of every topic
that you can just like and so and and
even though I have studied religion for
the better part of a decade
there are so many like major religious
Traditions that I know
very little about
Luigi Super would you consider making
more videos about Zoroastrianism I have
been considering making one
more ones about zorationism I thought I
wanted to remake my original video about
zorationism but I went back and watched
that and I just I felt like that was
pretty good I have there's nothing
really to change what I would change of
course is like the production value like
better images and videos and just
that stuff but in terms of the
information and then and all that I was
pretty proud of that one so
I don't feel a need to remake that
anytime soon what I do want to do is is
I guess explore stuff like observanism
hope I'm correct it pronouncing that
correctly which is considered like this
heresy in zorationism
and so that that's been on my mind
lately that I should do a video about
that and just explore different aspects
of rationalism because it's not explored
as as much as it should be given how
significant of a religion that is
historically as I said in my original
video that probably is one of the most
influential and important religions in
the history of the world because it has
influenced
you know it's a lot of Christianity on
Islam and Judaism to such major degrees
it seems
so zorationism is something I want to
keep exploring absolutely
I'm what's really exciting is I'm
you know October is coming up
and so the stuff the scripts I'm working
on now are sort of related to
to that when we do our what we call
shocktober
um which shocktober series which is when
we get into the darker
aspects of of these things I sort of
turn into esoterica for a month
and uh so what I'm working on now in
terms of scripts are some follow-ups to
what I did last year about the occult
Sciences in the Islamic abroad in
particular
and so I'm doing one video about the
Hakim otherwise known as the picketrix
which is really cool
and then what I was just riding on
earlier today
was a script about the Shams the son of
knowledge which is this incredibly
famous or inFAMOUS book that um
you know is in some sufi's context is
used as a sort of spiritual book but
it's also considered in other circles to
be this dangerous book of magic that
will
you know get Gins to come to your house
just by owning a copy of the book right
so it's it's it's seen as one like the
dangerous uh book it has this reputation
of being being black magic and uh
it has a fascinating history and so I'm
working on a video about that which is
really cool
it's about Anwar asked what type of
music do you play I tried to play all
kinds of music
um in terms of what I've the music I've
released my own music has been
I guess two primary
things which sometimes intersect but
still I've sort of been doing sort of
rocks rock music like uh rock pop
in the earlier days I don't think it's
sort of metal-ish Music
um but then on the other hand I've done
more
by sometimes called sound tracking music
like ambient
music like on the album I released this
summer called climbing which was
basically just the background music to
these videos
and those two sides of my music up but
also intersect so I will sort of mix
rock music with
ambient
Arabic folk music and stuff like that
you can see some instruments behind me I
guess there's a
there are both like Fender guitars and
woods and a SARS over there which kind
of tells you a lot about what kind of
music I I do but I I you know I'm I
enjoy most kinds of music and I try to
explore music in the same way that I
that I do history and religion just
trying to absorb as much as I can
because
yeah I love that stuff
Han's ex are you excited for the new
Assassin's Creed I am actually I don't
know if any of you are into video games
um you know I mean I don't play as much
video games as I did when I was young of
course but there's this series called
Assassin's Creed
um which you know at this point I play
mostly because of the way they create
these historical locations is just
incredible like they did one on Ancient
Egypt and they did one on on ancient
Greece and they've just been able like
the people who do research on those
video games are insane they clearly have
really good advisors and researchers
because they managed to just recreate
historical locations like ancient Egypt
and ancient Greece in such incredibly
accurate and impressive ways
and so it's just announced the other day
that the next one is going to be
the setting for that game is going to be
in Baghdad in the 9th century
which immediately just
I was like you know I need I should
probably make some videos about that
right uh
maybe I'll do one of those
cheesy experts react to Assassin's Creed
and then I'll give commentary while
playing the game I don't know uh
I'm definitely looking forward to that
because I'll I'll um
even though
as I said I don't play as much video
games as I used to I
I would just love to see the way they
will recreate that world
and
so it's gonna take in like it's going to
take place in like 850 A.D or something
which means
that's like the height of the Abbasid
like right at the end of a Basset power
to some degree
but which also could include some really
fastening figures like some of the
earliest sufis and Proto sufis if they
choose to include that which I would
doubt
but also like alkindi was around at that
point so really cool if he shows up for
example
um we'll see I'll probably do some some
kind of coverage or video about that
when it comes out
I'm scanning for uh
scanning for some good questions here
will okay so um
sorry if I mispronounce all your names
by the way I try my best uh
gergely
zlagi asks if there will be a Zaid ishia
video and there will be
um
I am currently working on a video about
the ismaili so I'm doing a series about
Shia Islam
I did the one video about twelver she
ISM and the next one
is going to be about either the smiley
she is
and the script is basically done
for that so that should be coming out in
the near future and then after that I'm
also doing a video about the zadishia
I've been researching that lately
and yeah
it's really really fascinating stuff
so by the end of the year
you should know all about shiism
now that I've done this series of course
that's not true because there's an
infinite amount of stuff to to to learn
uh thank you again Isis Harrison for the
uh Super Chat uh he says I know this
might be a sensitive topic to ask
Muslims but why do the majority in the
hanafi school take the bukhari Hadith
collection as sahih
when there are some hadiths that insult
Muhammad and his wives
uh
I'm not a Hadith scholar I I don't know
if I can answer that uh question
in a proper respectful way
um
I don't know which hadiths you are
referring to
I have I have far more experience with
the actual Quran than with the Hadith so
I don't I mean of course I've studied
Hadith but I I don't feel like I have
enough knowledge to to answer that
question if anyone in the chat has
knows has a good answer to that then
then feel free to to leave a comment
I do believe in evolution
I assume you you mean
evolution in terms of darwinian
Evolution as it as an explanation for
the origin of of species in the world I
do think that that is currently
the the most um
looking forward the most uh
probable explanation for how all these
different species of animals and and so
on came to be over time
I feel like it's a it's a it's a theory
that I
that I trust to some degree absolutely
how about doing a video on taoism I have
several videos on taoism already I have
one called what is Taoism I have one
dedicated to drones in particular the
second most famous book slash author
from that tradition and I have one on
the nadan or uh
inner Alchemy in that
religion slash tradition as well so
check out that stuff it's under one of
my playlists called
what's it called
disputing the Dao right religion in East
Asia
donkasaurus Rex great name
asked what is the best thing to see if
you're a tourist in Sweden
me of course now
um I don't know if in Sweden
I've never seen the Northern Lights
which is a tragedy but I'm sure that
would be really cool if you're up here
in like winter time you can go to the
North of Sweden
um
Stockholm is nice
of course I think Stockholm's nice
because this is where I live but
um a lot of museums in Stockholm if you
like that sort of stuff
um
the
it's called it's called in Swedish
what's the English name archipelago
yeah it's it's a yeah it's there's a
place called quagon which is outside
it's a part of Stockholm essentially
it's really beautiful
um and there are like forests
also like the nature is beautiful here
right there's a lot of Woodland there's
a lot of really sort of relatively
untouched nature that's really beautiful
I would say that for me that's that's
one of the things I I love about this
place
here's an interesting question Daniel
Stanton what do you think it means for a
religion to be true
it's a very good question I guess one
answer that question is
I don't know
I guess I really lived in this true
if the religion
has a
I don't know I was going to say
something like that religion is true if
it has a positive effect or something
like that but I don't know like
that's a good question because truth is
is a difficult topic
I'm not going to answer I'm not gonna
I'm not going to get into a long
unprepared philosophical rant about what
truth is here but certainly a good
question
poets you would recommend for beginners
other than drew me well room is great as
long as you're being a
um
proper translation
common barks translations are
I mean they're pretty they're beautiful
but a few most of you know that they are
um problematic for various reasons they
are very free
interpretations in terms of how they are
translated and often
suck out all relation to Islam from
Rumi's poetry there but there are
beautiful translations other than that
Rumi I don't know I think
I mean I love people like sushdari Abul
Hassan
I should study I like Urban Arabi of
course
surprise I also like it means because I
read you know I know a little Arabic and
I don't know any Persian so I sort of
gravitate towards Arabic poets like an
Arabi like within farted
but they can also be more difficult like
even in translation
um
it can be a little more difficult to to
read those Arabic poets
um
because it's and this is true for the
Persian poets also but they are so
just
bathing and all this
vocabulary and and references to
poetic forms from ancient Arabia and
like you you gotta know the particular
symbolic language that they're using to
to get anything and that's true of the
Persian poets too but I feel like many
of those Persian poets like Rumi and
Hafiz and all those people are a little
more accessible in some regards like
anyone can pick up a decent translation
of Rumi and sort of
enjoy it and get what he's trying to say
um
room is good
so two of my favorites so I love Mahmoud
shall be study so if you can get a
if you can get a hold of the golshan
IRAs in Translation or if you know
Persian you can read in Persian The
Garden of Secrets or the Rose Garden Of
Secrets by Mahmoud Shah bistari I think
is a magnificent
work of Sufi poetry
a couple of super chats Alex badilla
thank you so much
uh what are you planning on covering
next with respect to Buddhism our
Buddhist so I am biased
well I I love Buddhism too I'm also
uh
somewhat biased I guess now I'm
I'm gonna particularly I think focus on
East Asian Buddhism that's what I've
studied the most and that's what I've
been most interested in
um I did the one on agarajuna which sort
of laid the groundwork for that
um a lot of Mahayana tradition
so two videos
probably the next two I'm doing is on
the one hand a video about Tian Thai
Buddhism
Associated primarily with the figure
called
and here's me trying to pronounce
Chinese but it's he's called z z z
anyway uh Tian Thai Buddhism which is
associated with this idea of
the three truths rather than the two
truths Theory
it's known in Japan as 10 die Buddhism
uh that is next probably and then I'm
doing one on Zen Buddhism or Chan
Buddhism in Chinese
so those are the two
major next one that I have in mind and
then
beyond that I'm not sure there are
plenty of stuff I I can
cover
then we have Ari meme thank you so much
also for the Super Chat have you ever
had a remarkable religious experience
love you work thank you so much uh
I guess I've talked about this
previously
um
you know
I don't know if my if
my student is still left in the chat
because then this is going to be
embarrassing but uh actually
one of the most major spiritual or
religious experiences probably was
you know be working as a teacher for the
last two years nothing has been so
spiritually fulfilling and and
meaningful in my life previously uh
so
you know just being able to work
with these you know these students
yeah it was just so meaningful that and
and
I'm reminded of I talked with zevi and
Justin about this in one of our private
conversations that I'm reminded of
something that
um Sean nimatula the the founder of the
nematullahi Sufi order said that
you know choose spirituality right true
spirituality is
not going off to the mountains and
sitting in a cave meditating alone true
spirituality is you know being in the
world and being there for other people
you know loving other people and and
helping
uh participating and and being a
positive light for other people and I
felt like
having that job and working with those
students was exactly that for me and so
that was incredibly powerful in so many
ways that's probably the most powerful
spiritual uh religious thing that I've
that I've ever done
[Music]
uh let's see
thank you user user for the Super Chat
what are your thoughts on alavis so
there are many groups called the alavis
I guess when it's spelled like that it
usually refers to the Anatolian group
um I did a video about the alavis
actually that was back in
must have been 2020 I filmed it in 2017.
what sort of a documentary style video
that I did about the anavis
[Music]
um
and you know
I took that video down because it it
caused
um more controversy than I was
um
comfortable with I guess not because you
know
not because you know it was there was a
controversy around me doing a video
about the alavis but there were other
factors behind that and the people that
I interviewed and so on and and you know
there was just stuff that I was
uncertain about and had to rethink
certain things that just sort of made me
take that down and while I was
rethinking whether that should be on the
channel because of certain things that
were said and even though I actually
distanced myself from what was being
said
um people you know people aren't always
good at separating
between those things so um anyway that
video might come up at some point again
and regardless I'm probably going to
make a new video on the alavis just a
regular sort of lecture type of video
that I that I usually do
um I've I've had interactions with
alavis and they've all been lovely
wonderful people I think it's a
fascinating and Rich beautiful religious
tradition
um
yeah
Ron thank you so much for the Super Chat
uh video on shavism coming soon
yeah I've been meaning to do that video
on Kashmir shaivism for a long time now
not quite there yet I haven't started
writing I'm still sort of slowly
researching that stuff but yes I'm doing
videos on shaibism in particular the
next one the first one is going to be on
on Kashmir shaivism which hopefully is
going to come out this year at least but
I'm you know I'm not going to make any
promises
aftabcon what's your take on Shamus book
so as I said I'm currently working on a
video about the shamsalmative which is
going to be part of the shocktober line
of videos proudly I think it's a really
interesting book and I don't want to
talk too much about it because I want to
leave it for the video but it of course
has a really interesting history the
shamsam Arif which is usually called
today the shamsam Cobra the great son of
knowledge that we have today you know
the one that's printed and spread around
it's attributed to a 13th century Sufi
called Ahmad al-buni
but in reality the Sham salmanif as we
know it is most likely a compilation in
from the 17th century which includes
certain sections from his writings but
which is not identical to his
his actual work called
um
and so I'm doing a video that that
covers that sort of History you know who
was who was what did he write you know
he so he's strongly connected to people
like about Arabi and his ideas because
they grew up in that North Africa
speculative Sufi tradition which
includes these ideas about you know the
the science of letters the element
and all this stuff and
writings is essentially that so they are
Sufi writings but they include these
practical sort of occult scientific
aspects that were usually not written
down they were only transmitted orally
esoterically from teaching to student
and what seems to have been uh
special about Ahmed al-bunis that he
actually wrote it down in a text which
survives and which which is why that
stuff became so strongly associated with
him and so the video is going to be
essentially exploring him
and the history of that text and then
also of course exploring the contents of
fishham Cinema RF as we know it today
um
it's a fascinating book right it's one
of the most famous and one of the most
interesting books in terms of
the history of the occult uh it includes
all these kinds of things you know as
you know astrological not so much a
Charlie but you know the science of
letters
um you know gin stuff summoning gin it's
it's dark stuff really
um
but yeah it's it's fascinating there's a
translation actually or a translation of
a section of that book that came out I
think this year
but a lot of people of course are very
careful about that book as they just
considered that that will bring on
um and I think this occurs around that
book that will bring on Jinn
so
I guess
if if you believe in that stuff then uh
be careful
um but if not then you know it's a
really interesting thing and I should
probably check out that translation
uh Tristan
make him make him thank you for the
Super Chat have you noticed this
tracking similarity in the imagery of
shamash and ahura master do you think
there's a connection between Beyond
imagery
I did notice that I noticed it
particularly even more so when I was
editing my video about agent Mesopotamia
and I was you know
studying and getting all these images of
of you know depictions of these gods and
uh shamash
as as well as you know ashur
the Assyrian God
the imagery for that compared to
depictions of ahora Muslims rationalism
is very similar and probably you know
you can hear you can tell by the names
that's probably you know it is probably
etymology
etymologically connected some degree I'm
not sure I could be wrong but um
yeah there's probably a direct
connection I don't know enough to to
speak on it but there seems to be a
connection there
certainly between ashur and Mazda in
terms of shamash
I'm sure
I'm sure there's a connection there too
I don't know
I think there's a connection yes to
answer your question
and maybe I can explore that further in
a future episode
once again thank you so much what's your
review on state religion
did any religion on Earth ever profess
to their followers to create a state or
Empire
yeah sure I think well you know going
back to Mesopotamian religion I think
you know the religious Cult of ancient
Mesopotamia was so strongly connected to
the um city-states and the the political
structures and the Empire from the very
beginning like they grew up side by side
and then interconnected with each other
um so it's not like the religion came
about and said you should create an
empire and then they created the Empire
they sort of grew up together but that's
one example I guess
um
those kinds of old ancient religions
often function that way right that all
these features that we usually separate
today like politics and religion and
culture those things were not separated
back then and so the religious
Cults and the religious beliefs and all
that was intimately connected and
developed in tandem with
with the the political States and these
empires in terms of these so-called
revealed religions
um I can't think of of any that sort of
explicitly you can interpret these
religions as doing that certainly some
interpret Islam as
um calling for the creation of some sort
of State
um you know people like those who call
themselves the Islamic State do that uh
other others don't see that directly in
in that certainly Islam
includes
social and political aspects in its sort
of core teachings but it isn't clear to
me at least that there's a call for for
uh for an Empire or a state in at least
not in the
the primary sources of that religion
um Christianity definitely not
um
no no but I think in terms of many
religions that would be true especially
those ancient religions which grew up uh
together with certain civilizations and
civilizational structures and states
how long have been streaming I've been
streaming for 48 minutes okay so we can
go for a little by more
nice to see you again we will talk in
detail about uh myitasalism
maybe do you guys is there an interest
in that then I could definitely talk
about them
they are the earliest theological
schools in the Islamic tradition
earliest Islamic school in the Islamic
tradition
[Music]
um
I did cover them of course in my
introductory introduction video to
Islamic theology way back when
they are they make up a significant
section of that video but uh
could definitely do just an episode on
them eventually
they have they have become more popular
there is more interest in the IMO in the
last century for example and I think
there's a growing interest even today in
that so
they're an important parts of that story
so definitely
I mean are you familiar if there were
agnostic philosophers or scientists that
left some Legacy or someone wrote about
them in Middle East pre-19th Century
agnostic
I mean agnostic is a rather recent term
it depends on what you mean there are
certainly figures who seem to reject the
religious
the organized religion you could say
other religious structures uh like the
famous Arabic poets
um who is often depicted as a vegan
atheist or something he wasn't that he
was actually a very Pious religious
person although he did uh
I mean the vegan thing is kind of
Justified although
sort of anachronistic but he did abstain
from eating meat and stuff
um
but he definitely criticized Islam
and many of the sort of structures of
Islam as it existed in his day but he
was not sort of you know he wasn't
irreligious
in that way it was an atheist
um
I'm trying to think
of course there are there are those
figures definitely I'm just not they're
I'm just I can't remember them right now
uh give me some give me some
suggestions in the chat maybe
that's an interesting
although I I don't know is an
interesting figure
he he's one of the most famous poets
Persian poets uh and there is sort of a
debate among Scholars and and so on
whether he can be considered a
Sufi poet
because he talks about all these things
that sufis talk about like wine and
being intoxicated and beautiful women
and all these things
and in Sufi poetry that stuff is is
metaphors for you know wine is usually a
metaphor for you know love for God and
being intoxicated you know being
intoxicated in this love for God and
Union with God uh you know a beautiful
woman is usually also a sort of metaphor
for God
uh in in hayam P you know Scholars
aren't sure if he is using the wine as a
metaphor or if you just really liked
wine
um so he's he could be one of those
examples although I wouldn't
I'm no expert on hayam uh I don't know
if he was agnostic it's possible he did
sort of deny an afterlife though right
because in his poetry he seems to be
have this idea that you know we should
just enjoy life while it lasts because
you know there probably isn't anything
after
um and that's how I remember that that
poem at least that could be
misremembering it
yeah Abu Bakr I was also thinking about
him
um
but you know then again we have to
really consider what we mean by agnostic
because he still had these ideas these
metaphysical ideas about you know into
not intellect but but these Divine
principles and so on so so you see an
agnostic then I don't know
uh there is a super chatty Umar Ahmad
the medieval Islamic philosophers
integrated The Works of both Plato and
Aristotle into their philosophies yes
sometimes unknowingly because they
thought that they were reading the works
of Aristotle when they were reading uh
platinus
um
yet they seem to be diametrically
opposed in contemporary philosophy do
you know well yeah so that's basically
why
um
Aristotle and Plato are very different I
mean they agree in some regards of
course but um
in the Islamic world as I said the you
know at least in the first couple of
centuries Aristotle was seen as you know
the greatest philosopher and there was
this work called the Theology of
Aristotle which was the sort of
I guess the core text that they used as
a source for Aristotle's philosophy and
for Greek philosophy in general which of
course we know now is not Aristotle's
work at all but it's the section from
the
more sort of pair of a paraphrase
section from the any ads by platinus who
is a neoplatonic philosopher
um
and so in that regard you know a
neoplatonism in a way does try to fuse
ideas of Plato and Aristotle but of
course Legions have it towards Plato
um
and so that's why so two the Muslim
thinkers
there was very little difference between
Aristotle and Plato at least in these
early centuries
um
until you know we get to something like
the 12th century with IBN Rush who
started realizing that you know a lot of
these ideas that have been seen and
these people are talking about are not
Aristotelian at all they are neoplatonic
ideas and so we started uh criticizing
them and instead returning to the actual
works of Aristotle and on the other hand
you had people like Surah vardi who went
the opposite direction and turned
against
um aristotelianism to some degree and
instead embraced a more platonic kind of
philosophy in many ways
so it is a it is a sort of result of
historical circumstances and
misunderstood translations and so on
that but also of course a result of the
syncretic
philosophy to some reason it's a great
philosophy of neoplatonism that try to
to harmonize Plato and Aristotle in some
way
AKA Ahmed a universal Court you love
among all the religious beliefs you
have to share Universal quote
I mean the golden rule is the first
thing that comes to mind
which seems to exist in some form in
most religions you know due to others as
you would have them do unto you
it's a pretty good
pretty good rule too to live by I think
makes a lot of sense and works
it's very uh
it's very useful
Isis Harrison thank you again do you
believe that psychedelics are the last
gateway to the divine
in the 21st century now that we are
immense in technology and consumerism
how do you mean the last Gateway
I think so you know I don't condone
psychedelics for the record right but I
think seems to me like uh you know
experiences people are having on those
kinds of substances are very similar if
not identical to many experiences
described by Mystics and and these kinds
of people in history so I think
um and you know research shows that some
of this stuff can be useful in a medical
way for you know various treatments and
so on
so
that's not relevant to this discussion
but um
there's definitely a connection there
um you know defining the Divine as that
experience that all these people are
reporting
it there seems to me there seems like it
seems like that same experience
some degree can be had with these
substances but I I don't know
um
now that we are immensing technology so
you mean like this is like do you mean
like this is the last hope that no no
people are not don't have the the
capacity to to reach those states by
other means anymore uh um I wouldn't
I wouldn't say so uh and I think any
sort of substance that
that
gives you that experience
in a way that's very sudden and without
the proper sort of build up to that can
be probably harmful
if if a miss
if abused essentially but uh yeah I
shouldn't speak too much on this
Gonna Get You know they're gonna shut
down the stream or something
I saw some good questions Rudy is your
best religion well uh no
just kidding
I'm not gonna do that
would you film a video on Islam and
astrology Scotty Garner I did already I
did a collaboration with Angela puka
back in January I think which covered
astrology in the Islamic world so check
that out
what do you think about wahhabism
I said what I had to say I guess in my
video about salafism
I'm not gonna
I'm gonna talk about opinions I think in
that way
it's an interesting movement
Earth alien top 10 religion video I did
that actually uh that was also an early
video I did on the channel
just sort of Click sort of a click bait
because it wasn't top 10 best religions
obviously it was top 10 largest
religions in the world
so if you're interested in that then
that is also on the channel
again a lot of Islam questions and uh
I'm gonna get to those two
but I'm also sort of trying to scan for
other questions so it doesn't get so you
know one-sided this discussion
thank you
very kind words also by a lot of your
compliments and so on I thank you so
much I I do see the comments and I
appreciate them very much
uh thank you it means a lot when when uh
you know just hearing that my videos
have a positive impact in some way just
you know you learn something new or you
know you some people say they use the
videos to to fall asleep which you know
is a nice thing I think you know if if
it brings them if it can bring them to a
state where they feel safe and
comfortable enough to fall asleep then
that makes me happy
um I also love encountering you guys out
in the the real world I
met one of you yesterday here in
Stockholm
[Music]
which in all in those kinds of
encounters are always lovely sometimes
you know I feel like I'm I'm not the
best conversationalist
um and uh
I'm a bit of an awkward person sometimes
but you know regardless I hope you all
know that I really appreciate and I love
talking to your guys
um and hearing
yeah just just meeting you guys is
always wonderful
we have a super chat from a person with
uh
you know letters that I cannot read but
thank you so much what is a most
interesting point of a new confusionism
as you see
yeah so neoconfusionism I was I was I
was getting into neo confucianism
last winter
and uh I don't I I didn't get that far
but I think the way they in many ways
sort of synthesize ideas from you know
taoism Confucianism and Buddhism
it's really interesting and they turn a
lot of these ideas of Confucius into uh
these new and deeper Concepts in a way
that I think is fascinating
um
that's all I can really say because I
well for one thing I don't remember
enough to to speak comfortably about it
but
but yeah I really appreciate the way
that they
were able to take all those major
religious slash philosophical traditions
in China and sort of create this
semi new thing that became the of course
as far as I understand the sort of
Orthodox or the official uh
cult right in China for for many
centuries
so here's a lovely comment Bob Ross Bob
Ross says your videos got me through
chemotherapy so what like just reading
those kinds of comments is just
really warms my heart
I'm just you know I just I'm just
interested in religions and history and
I make these videos and I I'm excited
about these topics I want to I want to
share my excitement with you
um so hearing that kind of stuff really
is so lovely
the sorry okay so I'm gonna here's an
Islam question uh the eagle eyed was IBN
arabi's teachings accepted by asharis
asharis and mataridis well by some and
not by others always been a
controversial figure so some accept him
some don't
but people within those Traditions have
often accepted his ideas yeah
[Music]
one one such figure that just
I just came up in my head as
ASI was a 17th century ottoman
scholar Sufi from from Damascus and he
was a strong adherence being a great
defender of of his philosophy but was
also very
um
devoted
ashari
Theologian or you belong to that that
School of Theology right so
so PR people from all kinds of positions
except generally you know salafis and
wahhabis tend to have accepted IBN Arabi
he's been he's he's been everywhere in
that sense even though he sort of
critiques all the schools of theology he
critiques the asharis critiques the law
and he sort of
but he also sort of draws from all of
them in some way he's he's such a unique
figure like if you ever I've started
reading the photahat again like the
translation of the futa Hotel Makia
translation by um
Eric Winkle the other day and it's just
like just reading like some people
you just read their words and it's
there's like a
I don't know how to describe it it's
just so unique he's so original
and everything has such high stakes all
the time you read that introduction
where he describes how he meets the
youth and he reads the whole book on the
body of this Youth and it's just this
imagery
um it's incredible some writers are just
able to you know some figures in history
you know but Nabi is one of them where
you just you just completely immersed in
a different world when you read that
stuff and the mystics particular are
really good at that stuff
thank you so much for the Super Chat
that's true of course translations are
always interpretations and you can never
recreate the original
um but you know you can still get a
sense of of what he's saying can still
get a sense of the imagery
um you know translations aren't
completely useless
um you can still capture a lot of of the
essence of a book through a translation
but it of course it will never be it
will never be the same
as as the original
which is particularly true
when you read something like that
whether it's poetry which is so
dependent on on the original language
but also something like a mystical
Treatise like that because he these
Mystics play around so much with with
the language because words have
different connotations so one of the
famous
primary words that uses is of course he
doesn't use that word so much but words
that that is associated with
being right existence and but that word
you know in Arabic it comes from the the
root rajada and which means finding
essentially so would you means to find
um and and the same root is also used to
mean ecstasy in in in Sufism and so when
he uses words like that
it can mean any of those different
things right you mean being it can mean
finding it can mean uh you know and or a
lot of time it means all those things
simultaneously and so you gotta have
first of all
you have to be aware of the original
language and the way he uses the
original language to get the full extent
of what he's saying we also gotta have a
huge knowledge and experience with that
language and all its connotations and
the meanings to fully appreciate what he
and I don't have that knowledge of
Arabic and you know I I can read Arabic
and I understand very basic Arabic but I
I don't have that knowledge which is why
it's great to have commentaries by
people who have that expertise anyway
there's certainly a a point to what
you're saying that translations are
always compromises but I still feel like
they are useful
philosophy
foreign
well I know
why do I know I I know the basics I
guess he's a pre-pathetic philosopher I
know of his famous argument for the
existence of God I know of the floating
man arguments I know the you know
I have a basic overview of what he's
saying I'm no expert on ibnc now you can
turn to
various
people
uh
Peter Adamson is great for that for
example
by the way speaking of Peter Adamson I'm
sure many of you have heard his podcast
uh the history of philosophy without any
gaps but if you're interested in the
history of philosophy that is one of the
best
sources you can you can get
uh ISO Cyrus and again thank you so much
this may be more geopolitical than
religious but can you do a video on
Jewish nationalism and how it branded
itself introduce
uh maybe that's you know
I try to keep out of
overtly political topics as much as
possible
of course it is impossible to not talk
about politics when you discuss religion
because they're so interconnected
um
but you know there's a way to do that
video that is respectful and and
neutral and and
informative I think
it's gonna come with a lot of
controversy regardless of what I do but
you know that's what you gotta
you have to be ready for that when you
make these kinds of videos but
um yeah I don't know that much about it
I could of course do something with one
of my colleagues who probably know a lot
more about that stuff
here on YouTube
um
I'm open I'm definitely open to that
suggestion
I cannot speak Persian
I do know as I said I do know a little
Arabic
I can read better than I can speak as is
usually the case I can read I can
understand you know my wife's family are
you know Arabic speakers and so I I and
you know Iraqi dialect in particular I
can sort of pick up on what they're
saying if they're having a conversation
but in terms of me speaking that's when
it gets more difficult
uh at least speaking fluently
I can read aloud from a text of course
but having a conversation is like I'm
not
I'm not at that level because I studied
Arabic at University a couple years ago
um but I've had sort of a break in that
for like three years at this point
because I focused so much on other stuff
like this channel so I haven't been able
to to
um develop my Arabic skills as much as I
would have liked to but I have I have
that basic
I have a basic uh proficiency I guess
alhamdulillah
and I failure order yeah
in all these Sufi orders I'm Gonna Do
videos about them eventually
um the cloud that you order order
um nav Levy order
what else I was gonna do one on
probably like the big Tashi order is
also interesting
I'm gonna
a couple of more minutes
and then we're probably gonna
be done for today
but this is good like I said I haven't
done this in a really long time and so
it's good to to get back on the horse I
really love talking to you guys and I
want to do that more often but you know
things get in the way
like making videos for example uh
but I'm trying to see you thank you for
the Super Chat as an Arab
even Arabi was a hundred percent with
the destination
but krishnamurthy easily pointed out the
path and not the destination what do you
think
do you mean like IBN Arabi had
arrived at the destination and then sort
of describes
what the destination is like whereas
someone like Krishna murti describes the
path to get to that
[Music]
um
I feel like even Arabi is is also very
he spends a lot of time trying to
explain about the path as well a lot of
his works are dedicated to precisely
that you know again Going Back to the
Future heart which I was reading again
the other day
you know several books
so that's a that's a mess so photo hat
is like 10 000 pages in this translation
in this translated form it's going to be
19 volumes and I think it's 30
what is it like 38 books in total and
several of those books are just
dedicated to
questions of
like Islamic law basically so he'll go
into details of you know is
if you're out in the desert and you
don't have access to water and you need
to do ablutions before praying how do
you do it do you use the sand do you you
know how how do you hold your hands
during prayer what do you do when you're
fast and this and that happens you know
these kinds of very minute details about
uh point you know details about Islamic
law
he tends to be rather lenient he's very
none of his interesting because he's
really strict about following the law
um he's like almost radically uh very
very strict with his students that you
know following the Sharia is like
very but then when it comes to the
actual details of what that means he
tends to be relatively lenient
um he usually chooses the option that is
most
um
yeah that is easiest for the
practitioner with the sort of
justification that you know it says I
think in the Quran that God has made God
has made your religion easy for you and
that he sees
uh Muhammad
as the as being a mercy to the world and
he sees himself like ebenez himself as
he calls himself the unlimited mercifier
right so he comes to to make thing to
make things easier for people and so for
example you know he famously in the
photohati states that women can lead
prayers in in you know congregational
prayers even it seems mixed
um prayer Gatherings women can lead
those prayers and he has Arguments for
why right so it's really fascinating
that he goes into these details but he
also tends to be rather uh at least in
my sort of reading of him and how I
understand it it seems to be
relatively lenient in these details in
these questions
[Music]
you'll find out once that video comes
out which is relatively
timestamps uh are you do you mean in my
videos I've tried to to implement some
timestamps in some videos I did one on
the Ahmad Bamba video
I think that may be it
now the Sikhism video has times two like
chapters I mean I should do that more
especially in those long videos
Christos nicolao nice to see you again a
frequent visitor and commenter on this
channel which obscure sect you've ever
heard of do you wish we had more
information about
all of them
um
good question again good question you're
putting around the spot with these
questions because I probably have some
great answer but um
just
blacking out
um
I miss some of those ancient religions I
would love to know more about details
about Mesopotamian religion for example
um manichaeism
yeah I should
please make a video about Pablo Escobar
um
please make a video about
African sufis well so I did I did the
one on Amanda Bamba
so that's sort of a way into that I also
uh did documentary a few years ago about
the tijaniya Sufi Brotherhood
so
I uh I've done a few but of course I
want to do more because it's a lot of
Sufism in Africa is
is really a topic that is massive and so
rich and interesting but which is not
covered as much as it should be I did
focus on so when I did my both my
bachelor's Theses and thesis and
Master's thesis I they were both focused
on West African Sufism
so it's actually kind of one of my main
fields of expertise
which means I should talk about it more
on this channel
so I probably will
scrolling for questions
thoughts on how many
I don't know I don't know
it's a he's interesting he's one of the
most influential figures of the 20th
century of course
he was heavily involved in
[Music]
erfan as it's known
philosophy and mystical philosophy in
the
no they don't call it Sufism there in in
trouble she is and mostly at least they
call it erfan which is the sort of the
philosophical speculative aspects of
Sufism but not the Practical aspect like
mullah saddara for example like he was
an expert on that stuff which a lot of
people don't know
um he I've said this in a previous live
stream I think but he also
uh in the late 80s he uh
sent a a copy of
these great work to Gorbachev in the
Soviet Union
so that he would
hopefully convert to Islam
which is a just a fascinating story and
it shows you that how many was so deeply
involved with with these you know Sufi
traditions
and that I I've found that many people
are surprised when they hear that um
median fire says that I am nothing and
that I have no core
and uh
truer words
have rarely been spoken
all right Gorbachev passed away recently
I forgot
also really you know influential and
important figure of the 20th century
certainly regardless of what you uh
I think about him right
I hope he finds uh hope he has a restful
or it's a peaceful rest
of the music channel going thank you
thank you for for asking it's going
pretty good I think um I'm just happy
that I've been able to be more active in
terms of the music stuff this year I did
have that as one of my goals at the end
of last year that I wanted to be you
know do more music
um be more active on that channel which
is you know my other channel called
Philip home which is dedicated primarily
to music and I've been pretty relatively
active
on that which is happy so you know
um so just based on that I think it's
going great
Okay so we've been going for almost an
hour and a half Let's do let's do five
more minutes and then we'll round out
do you have any particular musicians
that Inspire on work uh well I have a
lot of musicians that inspire me
um
one of the recurring figures have always
been
people like Peter Gabriel
I think a lot of you can probably if
you've heard my music you can probably
hear that
there's an album he did called passion
which was the soundtrack to a film
called The Last Temptation Of Christ
which um I jokingly said a few months
ago that I've realized that my whole
music career
has sort of always just been me trying
to do
that album
that but there's a lot of you know I
also love like the Beatles you know I'm
just all kinds of music
Bob Ross do you add milk and sugar to
your tea no mostly not
I I'm not I'm not a I'm not a
I'm not a
purist I don't you know I don't mind if
people want to drink their tea with milk
and sugar that can that's also delicious
sometimes if it's the right kind of tea
you know an Earl Gray tea or English
breakfast blend with milk is can be
really tasty but usually I I don't
do that
I'm the I'm the pretentious guy who
drinks you know Chinese oolong
teas
loose leaf
without any sugar or milk
uh recommend some books for knowledge
well books are great but also you know
zevi my good friends have you from
Seekers of unity said the other day you
know sometimes you just gotta put down
the books and go out and
be in the in the real world you know and
do some voluntary work or help some
people out or just do the most mundane
thing so as long as you do the most you
know
I've said you know the some of the most
spiritual things you can do is is those
you know the stuff that is the most
mundane as long as you do it with you
know intention and and awareness and and
presence and so on so
and as I said with my work at the school
for example that's been more spiritually
meaningful than anything I've done so
that's my cop-out answer by the way
because I
know there are a million books
um
check my uh
you know if you're interested in a topic
then I've covered in a video then go to
that video and check the description
because there's always a list of sources
and recommended readings related to that
topic
that's my
that's my tip
I do like pizza Joseph I do
I'm a simple man
Joe Paisano do you fast sometimes yeah I
fasted
I have joined my Muslim
friends sometimes even fasting during
the month of Ramadan
and other kinds of fasting too I think
you know if done
responsibly and and
right it can be a very uh
meaningful experience uh that's my
experience at least it's been very uh
you know I've I've I think I've
developed a lot
during those periods of fasting you
learn a lot about yourself
when you do that kind of thing
thoughts on Islamic feminism
yeah I guess I have many thoughts on
that I think
I admire people like I mean for example
and I'll probably cover that in some
videos in the future
that's my answer to everything but
that's you know that's the thing about
this stuff you can I can make videos
about basically any topic because
there's always some kind of connection
to something relating to religion
anyway we've gone for an hour and a half
now
I think it's time for me to sign off and
uh
spend some time with uh with my wife
but um it was as always really lovely
speaking with you guys and answering
your questions I I'm sorry I couldn't
get to all of your questions obviously
um but I hope um
hope my answers were
satisfactory or that my
voice was soothing enough that this was
a pleasant experience in some way I'll
try to do this soon again but that's
what I said last time and that was like
four months ago so but I will I will I
hope I will be able to do this again in
some future uh you know maybe some
weekend in the in the near future in in
any case you will you will see me in my
videos that are there's a few really
interesting one coming out soon and you
can also check out of course the podcast
there's a let's talk religion podcast uh
just call let's talk religion which is
on Spotify and all that stuff it's
it's my videos in audio form but if you
wanna
learn about
um
the Ebu nights while you're on the bus
then check out the let's talk religion
podcast and yeah thank you all for
showing up and uh
hope you have a great evening or day or
morning or whatever it is and I will see
you soon